hi this is joylyn savage I'd like to
talk to my parents
hi this is um Joycelyn savage I'm here
to talk for my parents
oh hello hi um hello the door for this
is mommy
hi I'm high this this is Joycelyn I just
want to let you know like right now I
need you to listen if I really listen to
me I have told you guys a million
million times that I am okay where I am
and I'm happy I just really want to let
you know that I'm telling you nobody's
listenin stuff so just me talking you're
all darkness is your daughter talking
I'm letting you know that I am okay and
I told you a million million times
plenty of times that I'm okay you know
that I'm happy you know exactly where
I'm at and you need to stop you just
need to stop it yeah okay
I love you too
I love you too please put mom back on
the phone
I love you too please put her back on
the phone and the speech I need to speak
to my like I said a million a million of
times mom I am NOT held hostage
I am NOT King do you hear me do you hear
me okay I'm happy where I'm at I told
you a million a million of times where I
am and I am very happy so please stop
what you're doing just just stop it okay
I give it you're saying but I need you
to understand I'm very happy okay
I don't I don't understand that but I'm
just letting you know I need you guys to
understand that I'm very happy
okay well I have to go now I have to go
now okay
all right guys love you